des événements de cette nuit sont un
tournant dans l'histoire de l'europe et
de notre pays
ils auront des conséquences durables
profonde sur nos vies ils auront des
conséquences sur la géopolitique de
notre continent et nous serons ensemble
y répondre tarik caille vous êtes à
l'elysée vous avez suivi ce conseil de
défense et donc emmanuel macron qui est
apparu très grave
tout à fait c'est un emmanuel macron au
visage grave et au ton ferme qui a donc
pris la parole il ya moins d'une heure
pour affirmer se tenir auprès de
l'ukraine auprès du peuple ukrainien
s'agit donc de la première allocution du
chef de l'état depuis plusieurs jours
sur cette crise craignant devant des
drapeaux français et européens et
ukrainiens le président français a donc
assuré se tenir aux côtés de l'ukraine
en affirmant que la liberté des
ukrainiens et celle des français le
président marchand a dit vouloir appuyer
l'ukraine en sans hésiter en prenant ses
responsabilités pour protéger la
souveraineté de sécurité des alliés
européens le président hama cran a
rappelé les efforts qui ont été menées
pour éviter la guerre il a ainsi accusé
le président russe vladimir poutine
d'avoir renié sa parole d'avoir refusé
la voie diplomatique et choisit la
guerre pendu le président russe a donc
décidé de porter la teinte la plus grave
à la paix et la sécurité de l'europe
depuis des décennies le président mâcon
a également parlé de sanctions de
sanctions militaires économiques et dans
le domaine de l'énergie cependant il est
resté assez flou sur la nature de ces
sanctions en raison de ce flou l'asse se
trouve justement au niveau de ces
réunions qui sont prévues tout au long
de la journée tout d'abord une réunion
du g7 prévue à 15 heures une réunion du
conseil de l'europe de l'union
européenne à 20 heures également à
sommet de l'otan prévu dans l'est
prochaines 12 heures donc quand le
président m'a qu'on parle de sanctions
toute la question est là jusqu'où iront
ces sanctions jusqu'où la france et les
alliés de l'ukraine il renvoie à
défendre la souveraineté de l'ukraine
toute la question est là merci tarik
caille depuis l'elysée roselyne febvre
on a entendu donc cet agenda très très
chargé pour emmanuel macron et
s'adressera donc demain au parlement
réunion également de l'otan demain et
puis aujourd'hui
visioconférence du g7 sommet
extraordinaire des européens à bruxelles
c'est la guerre et un agenda de
président de la république deux chefs de
guerre où j'aurai revenir quand même sur
les trois messages des manuels macron le
premier c'est un c'est un acte de guerre
et nous répondrons sans faiblesse donc
là typiquement emmanuel macron est dans
son rôle de chef de guerre et de père de
la nation la deuxième c'est cette nuit
est un tournant dans l'histoire de
l'europe et de la france pour bien
montrer que voilà l'affairé grave et que
peut-être que les choses ne seront plus
pareil en europe après cette attaque et
puis un troisième message qui est des
mad nature on ne le reverront ne le
relève pas suffisamment mais qui n'est
pas de nature à nous rassurer quand même
cette petite phrase emmanuel macron 17
détermination à protéger sans relâche
les français donc son allocution était
courte ce matin enfin tout à l'heure il
en fera sans doute d'autres mais c'est
vrai que c'est une façon aussi cette
petite phrase sibylline de dire je suis
là je vous protège ce qui induit donc
peut-être de mettre aussi un peu la peur
parce que si vous dites au français
voulaient protéger c'est qu'il ya une
crainte est une possibilité que les
choses tournent mal en tout cas c'est un
président qui veille à à tous
aujourd'hui
et comme vous l'avez dit son agenda de
président il il envoie un message au
parlement pour ne pas subir les attaques
d'un président qui
décide tout seul donc il y aura sans
doute dans les prochains jours très vite
un débat au parlement quelle pourrait
être la crainte pour les français
alors
envisagé au stade où on en est à l'heure
où on se parle insère les clés le
contrecoup des sanctions car si les
européens prennent des sanctions encore
plus ciblé encore plus massives contre
le régime russe et l'appareil économique
russe forcément un moment il y aura des
contres sanctions de la part de la
russie on l'avait vu d'ailleurs en 2014
certains secteurs de l'économie
française avaient été touchés notamment
dans l'agriculture on aime les éleveurs
de porcs qui avait perdu dès des
dizaines de millions d'euros qui n'ont
jamais vraiment retrouvé le niveau
d'avant 2014 d'ailleurs
et pendant ce temps d'ailleurs vladimir
poutine a essayé de deux d'autonomiser
plus son son économie pour qu'elle soit
moins dépendante en fait des
importations européennes donc il
pourrait y avoir pour certains secteurs
de l'économie des conséquences l'énergie
l'énergie évidemment ça pour la grande
majorité des français parce que
évidemment augmentation du prix du gaz
le blé également un
puisque la russie est un grand
exportateur alors les français côté blé
on n'est pas trop mal a garni si je puis
dire mais il ya quand même certains
produits issus du blé qui sont importés
en france donc il pourrait y avoir des
augmentations de prix dont va toutes ses
conséquences économiques après une
espèce d'angoissé diffuse et puis bien
sûr si jamais les européens les
américains l'otan décidé de changer leur
fusil d'épaulé alors la rencontre aurait
carrément dans une autre dans une autre
dimension militaire plus militaire pour
le moment tout ce que prévoit la france
est d'envoyer des renforts militaires à
son allié de l'otan à son ailier romain
pour sécuriser la grande frontière
finalement de l'otan et de l'europe
occidentale quelque part qui la sépare
de la russie sur près de 3000 km